I have friends who are black or my
producer is black should be accepted as
an argument against accusations of
racism I've been saying that about
Davies for years
[Music]
uh wrong wrong bucko I'm going to
challenge my inner inner uh Jordan
Peterson there I think it's a totally
acceptable yeah excuse well here's my my
only caveat is I don't think that you
should be offering like these desperate
defenses I'm not racist because however
like when it comes to actual defenses
I've always thought like having a black
friend is like yeah that's you're
probably not racist if you have a black
friend how is that not everyone's said
oh That's a classic That's a classic
racist say if you actually have a friend
who is of that race it's a pretty good
indication you don't hate people of that
race by the way most of the white Libs
don't have black some of them do I'm not
saying none of them have black friends
but a lot of them live in the most ly
white neighborhoods that exist and then
they attack those of us who have black
friends or black producers